hello and welcome everybody to another
night of chess and psychology today
i am hoping that we are going to be
really inspired by a buzzwinic and i
will continue to mispronounce his name
um i am
waiting to get confirmation
that i am live and going because every
single time all right yes i am live and
going this has been a great fear in my
life
that i'm not live when i think i'm live
so i'm um dealing with that
fear at the moment but it seems like
we're live we're good to go
so let's do it so
hello i see that we are getting viewers
um to join us as well
the first game that i want to talk about
is uh this one is richevsky
um but winnick and i feel like i'm just
pronouncing his name
and it feels so weird because i think
i'm saying it right but i know that
it's not the exact um ideal way so
ah all right
yeah yep not really yeah i agree
i see what you're saying brian yes all
right let me
make sure everything is good set and go
there's like three different
technology devices in front of me which
is
giving me a small headache but um
all right so
um for this game this was a world
championship tournament
in moscow and it was a quite
it was quite a very just one of those
games that i
wished i thought white was doing fine
and then i was like wait what happened
so let's let's go ahead and
um get a better dive in there
so i don't play this opening from
blackside i like playing
french from whiteside so you can imagine
that i am hoping
that white is the one well i was hoping
that i saw the game and i'm like no i'm
not hoping that white wins this game
and um so i do i play this line myself
it's the main one um
called by c5s and we are
um in this line that's there's so many
books i've had
different video series on these for the
club
that we've talked about um i recommend
books for these but all of these i've
done from white
so now we're looking at a game from
black so it's a little little
weird for me but bear with me so
um but when i had previously played this
knight e7s
and it's could easily transpose to queen
c7
uh depending on how white you play it
because if you play
if you plan to play this queen c7
you can still do it after queen g4
2 and then we get into this super sharp
line
and even recently i've been trying to
learn
more of it from the white side and
there's like
there's so many different move orders so
many different some
ideas so gotta be very careful on that
uh but to be honest i don't think it
matters which one you get at first
if you plan to transpose
when played is 97 again however
in the game but winnick did not play
that
so let me ask you what do you think what
winnie did if not knight to e7
what other choices are available
you wouldn't have to spend too much time
on it
look it keeps getting cold and warm here
i'm not even sure what to wear at this
point right now freezing
it was fine like an hour ago
oh totally freezing yeah so um not
necessarily c takes d4 is possible but
uh if you take over here
it i mean it could easily transpose
again
but um careful because queen g7 is the
serious threat so we gotta try and stop
that
so that's kind of the idea how do we get
to stop that
or at least protect our g7 because when
we
if we were to play this 197 take now the
rook can run
and then we get to take and we want to
play this queen c3 so careful
there's so many different ways to
transpose
yep trying to move the f pawn is a good
idea so how about
f5 i like this f5 idea because
queen is defending my g7 if you decide
to take it oh well perfect i'll just
take that with the knight attack your
queen
this is still defended uh this
e4 square is kind of winking at me that
i developed next i can just shortcast lf
file
blah blah a lot a lot a lot of good
stuff happening
so um it's important to keep that
in mind all right so
in the game this had also happened to me
when i played this
as white and it's best to just
play queen g3 and kind of wait it out
trying to give these checks don't really
do you much
because always g6
that doesn't really make that much of a
difference
and or if you want to be super safe you
can't play queen f7 but
um i kind of like the idea of g6 so just
kick the queen farther away
you all you have you do have to be
careful with this bishop the
long term or later on but at the moment
this is fine
so in the game queen g3 was played now
what do you think we should do should we
try to get this knight out that night
should we do anything in the center a
lot of you might already know
these openings so
[Music]
it's perfectly fine if you want to share
your opening knowledge too
and it's just
trying to get the night out eventually i
agree that knight does
most likely belong to c6 because even if
it goes to d7
it's not gonna have a very bright future
ahead of itself
so i like this idea of getting the
knight out however
um taking either taking here or playing
knight e7
makes more sense at the moment
and so for example let's look at knight
e7 97 is not
what spot winnick played in this
specific game
but later on like 10 years and 50s and
60s but when you
did play this personally so for example
this is actually um
this is actually a line that was played
in
tall bottleneck in 1961.
so that's kind of an interesting one
because there's a 192 there's a kingly
one
and i really do enjoy this so
kingi wanna it's not the actual um
game that was played between taobao
twinic but
that i believe wait no actually it was
whoops my bad
and sorry it's so weird because i'm
looking for
what we need to win and he didn't so i'm
just going to show this
game to you really quickly it's not that
long it's maybe like five more moves
and it's very surprising so here
black made a mistake black played jerk
h8
and i say a mistake because if you feel
like you're trapping the queen right
however that is not true you are getting
your own coin trapped
boom
see your queen is trapped your queen
can't go anywhere
and you end up losing material
so let's go back
um instead of king d1
this idea with knight e2 is also
possible
but then you get your knight out and
then in fact four you just get fish a
lot eventually you're gonna do
lawn castle which is very common to do
in these type of games
and all right so
i'm gonna go back back back this is
another idea that could potentially be
i think this was another game that's uh
this is a game between uh byron
i might be saying that wrong you can oh
my god i because i'm
growing up i read all of these names in
part c so it had i felt like i learned
with a different pronunciation so but
this was a
game that platfonique was again black
this was in monte carlo
in 1962 68.
so um
anywho in this specific game against
roshavsky
uh but winnick did not play this knight
e7 nothing wrong with it
taking is a pretty cool idea too and if
white decides to recapture now what do
you think we should do
now can we do this 1987 does that look
like a good idea
i kind of like it there are no
objections i would really like to do
this
knight e7
because my d7 the fun thing is that now
if you take it that's gonna be pretty
horrible because
when you save this boom check and you
lose your rook
right because remember if you moves ago
there was a pawn of c5 so that doesn't
really help
so knight e7 any objections because it's
not like someone's pretty dope
all right so knight e7 we see the ideas
of queen c3 coming up so logically
bishop d2 stopping it again there are
other
ways of um
stopping this attacks but bishop d2
seems logical
could potentially want to go before d6-2
now what do you think we should do as
black
if you hear a meow that's what is the
cat because the weather
looks good it looks a little sunny so he
wants to go outside
but i gotta teach you
that king the one um almost are you
talking about king d1
right now yeah
um i'm not really the biggest fan of it
because
it's not i mean it's not like you have
to stop the c3 or you're going to lose
so it's not necessarily that um
that's severe of a threat to have to
stop
you could simply just like get your
bishop out i don't really recommend this
but you could just get the bishop out
and maybe like change a little
and then like try to get the night out
so do you have options
hello kitty you got attention good
practice for five minutes
oh okay cute cute kitty right here
exactly we should think of what would
pishi do
oh he's joining
all right nope he's gonna go hide behind
the laptop
i'm not entirely sure what's going on
with the cat but
uh here white point bishop d2 which is
understandable you wanna protect your c3
you wanna um not
let opponents you know jump around in
your squares
make sense doesn't it so here
black played castle
you guys are correct i saw there was a
suggestion of castle in the chat
at castel i like this idea with castle
because
um
[Music]
if you defend your g7 pawn you exactly
you have to develop so eventually this
light's gonna come out
the one like touching the mousepad when
there's a mask next to me
um yeah this mask gotta come out
oh who is white white is uh
roshavsky
so what else
so now what do you think blackjack white
should do see
why it's gotta develop but the thing
with
this is that in um
black kind of not got like a good deal
out of this french because
usually we're not used to seeing this
pawn on f5 is usually on a seven
and white has like this amazing bishop
over here
so it's a lot
it is possible that my cat is playing
with something
behind the laptop which he probably
is because he's a cat
so if you're hearing stuff that might be
it
or it's a bridge too everything is super
loud here man
all right
so now what do you think white [ __ ]
see the tournament after all time died
um
i want to say
yes but i i
need to double check on that almost
if you have more information on that
that would be amazing to
share too
i mean the the the age kind of
the age is closed but i don't think it's
that close because
um alvin died in 1946
this is 48 so
yeah yeah this is probably me
why is there a scratching sound over
here let me
try to see if i can
do a noise suppression
is here
come on microphone
let's go on a little mini trip
is this any better
yeah please let me know if this is any
better because
hoping it's not going to hurt my viewers
ears i like my viewer i don't want them
to
have ear pain all right great
all right i'm glad that this is better
so
um now after castle what do you think
should happen yeah let's get the bishop
out
how even though this bishop on d3 would
be much stronger if the pawn
was on f7 but that being said
bishop d3 makes sense and we also have
to keep in mind that this bishop the c8
bishop
is still weaker than are the other
bishops so we
should try to
[Music]
get rid of it so b6
so b6 now but when it wants to exchange
this light squared bishop
and then if we do that then c4
e4 they're all kind of weak so
that's the idea 92 boom
now white is trying to put up a fight to
try and keep the bishop for a little
while longer
but
um what do you think what do you think
now what
black should do should we take this
should we give it another
little few minutes what should we do
all right thank you almost that's very
very educational as
we should all know our chess history
yes
so this night this wasn't defeated
tournaments
that um we were thinking
or
alright but
so careful because right now my takes e6
is coming up
uh why not c3 to keep the bishop well if
you played c3
you're you would keep the bishop but you
would make my bishop a monster too
so my bishop on a6 even if you let's say
played like c3 here
and saved your bishop your bishop is
good but it's not that worth it
it's not really attacking much now my
bishop would be super duper
um keeping your king from
keeping your knights from developing and
also
what shall we do
here still attacking my e6 so i should
probably defend that right
[Music]
so let's defend that nobody's forcing me
to exchanging these bishops right away
now um in this game white ended up
taking bishop a6 but
in a different game let me also keep my
live in a different
game between um horton petrossian
in 17 in 1970
bishop b4 was played which is also quite
interesting because you turn it on you
try to
pin this maybe do a bishop d6 or
something you try to be cool
and just eh rick f7 careful because if
you take it knight h5 attacking g7 and
also knight f6
ideas and if you move it you lose your
f8 so be careful with that now if we
have seven um
this is a this is a whole different
dimension but
white played h4 you take take get the
knight out and get the rook out
and eventually black ended up winning
but you can see how this is such an
interesting
um idea to try for white with bishop b4
it's very tempting
yeah so but i think the biggest problem
is that this rook is so far
out of the game and black's pieces are
active
they could be better but they're just
they're just the right amount of active
so queen d7 take
take and thank you almost for confirming
that this
is indeed the tournament that we were
looking
up for and
this is the fita tournament after all
kind died and
but we need officially became world
championship
after this tournament not necessarily
this game
but i'm sure this one also helped him so
now queen goes to d3 again there is his
ideas with h4
but i'm not entirely sure how to think
about it
so what do you think
what should happen after h4
what do you think black should do
try for counter play maybe
but i think the first thing to do is
this rook f7
program 7 seems so weird to me because
i'm not a french player
but recap 7 is a very interesting move
because
kind of stops all these different
threads and for that
i like it so if h5f
now i get to do receive now i bring my
knight back
and protects my king and
boom roof c4 i like this it looks a
little weird
exactly kind of prophylaxis f7
yeah anyways this is not what happened
in the
game either which i'm not really
complaining about
so uh after knight takes a6
white played queen to d3
now what should happen
i agree i don't also like this my queen
is kind of tied up to this pawn
but the queen is still active it's
holding some squares it's holding some
some stuff from white back so it's not
the queen is not my worst
piece so what do you think we should do
i like this idea of getting my knights
activated so
let's say knight b8 now what do we do
here
we have we want to go up to c4
potentially like most likely we're going
to try and get this knight up to c4 so
let's say black
we knew what black wants to do let's say
white is trying to be persistent
players h4 avoid all this with g5 stuff
i don't i don't really think g5 was a
serious threat
at least not before whitehead castle but
h4 now let's get this knights rolling
now question should we do this knight
rolling or roxy8 which one do you think
is better
all right all right i see you guys like
the connecting of the rook
but see that's the thing if you bring
the rook to see it then you're gonna go
to c4
so is that what you're gonna try to do
honestly i think rxc8 is quite
interesting
and then you're bringing more pressure
to the z file then you're going to do
rook c4
but i still have an issue figuring out
where i want to place my light
even after that but i do think it's
quite fascinating and very interesting
to do this roux c8
anyways so
let's go with knight c6 let's follow our
plan
i also don't play french i agree
let's say rook comes up we're burning
this other rook king h8
trying to be very um
no i don't want to say defensive very
thoughtful
is my g6 horrible it's unnecessary
and the night on f4 looks a little
annoying
um we don't really
have to do that knight g6 just
yet it's like my problem is if you
played knight g6
let's say before rook g3 let's say we
played like
knight g6 right now my problem is even
if take take now i give it i give it
threats
i give this to be h5 to the rip g3
to the queen coming over here i give
this to
so many different things
i don't like that idea also if the
somehow the skin manages to move around
and rip comes to each one and h5
it's it kind of i have to it's not a
safe choice
so rock h3 now what
anything on roxy8 anybody has any
um
a little bit horrible yes i was trying
to sugarcoat it
i feel like if we have to do it we would
but
we don't and she can you stop playing
with that
he's sleeping on bubble wraps cause i
got
his pack of treats today
and he's sleeping on the package by kind
of waiting for me to be done so i can
start feeding him
all right so eventually the white team
will come under fire now
and i'm not gonna spoil it but yeah
yep yep fishy keeps rolling on that
and he's being too cute all right so
uh i like this idea of rook c8 now rook
g3 and king shades
uh there seem to be no objections to
rook c8 so i'm just gonna
keep rolling uh rook f7 was also played
in kasparov
short 1997 and um
well kasparov won because well kasparov
um but not it doesn't necessarily mean
that
this was a perfect game played so i'm
gonna also show this to you but i
wanna just show this to you quick very
quickly because
uh our main game is still quite ahead of
us
but in this game between kasparov and
short
kasparov played quite beautifully put
the king in a fake castle
made sure that the queen side is safe
dominated and then went to the king side
i love it i love it when it like
is playing over here and then play it
over there and yes
my cat is named cat in a different
language but still
cat what am i supposed to call it sophia
or brian it feels weird
it's a cat i don't wanna name my cat a
human name
anyways back from my cat philosophy
um all right so here
i'm just gonna ask this one question why
to move
what do you think we should do
i mean i could i guess i could copy
paste from all kind and
call my cat chess but then
no poor cat
maybe next one this one is my first cat
so we'll just call it cat
the next one i don't think i can call it
cat because in my mind cat was this one
so taking on g6 looks very delicious
but there is even something more
delicious than that
free stuff 1966 it's free
queen c2 ah queen is four i just wanna
roll my queen over here f4
take nine to five and boom
easy peasy right so easy
all right so this was a game that's been
because powerful short i'm gonna
jump back to the position that we were
at oh it looks so different
um and this is our game the main game
reshefsky
but winning so we are gonna try to push
through it
now after king and jake now what do you
think black should do
so remember there is a some sort of an
attack being formed it doesn't feel like
it's too scary but we still should be
cautious
so what do you think we should do as
black and i think i've made a horrible
mistake
that i did not leave coffee here i know
i made coffee what did i do with my
coffee
oh god i don't remember what did i do
with my coffee
or water for that matter ah
my brain is so full i need a little i
need a little
um contents deleting from my brain
i don't think we should we should be too
fast on jumping on c4
um don't
i believe that's what up
oh i do not remember anything from my
spanish
that's not good
um so
after h5 now what do you think we should
do
i don't think my g8 is the way to go
however i'm quite
i'm a little intrigued with this idea of
trying to get the knight up here
but i'm i'm afraid even if you get this
knight down to g4 then just one after
and the knight has to go back to h6
oh yeah ah thank you that flexible truth
keep giving me truth
all right so after h5
now what should we do i kind of like
this recap 7 we saw this recap 7 idea
earlier in different
ways that the game could be played so
why not
um so the thing is this h6 is going to
come up
even if you played my g8 h6 it could
still
be a problem for you because you weren't
exactly i mean even if you took it to
the knights then the h file is open
we don't really want to take that we
want to play this g6
and now it's kind of it's not of a
stable
position just for now and we're gonna
see how it's gonna unravel
so after g6
um white played rook c1
and now after rook c1 what do you think
we should do
this move was a little weird to me but
uh it's it's very it's doable you just
have to think
is this piece in its right place
i don't think knight a5 is i don't think
knight a5 is the way to go just yet
so not nothing you're all good
all right i see the idea of trying to
play knight to a5
but it's a little too early and
to be honest again this move really did
mess with my brain
he just went dirk back to f8 and after
the little maneuvering he played knight
b8 again
which i really really did not understand
because i thought that maybe knights
going to d8
and then trying to go to potential like
f7 and g8 and just like trying to keep
the king cozy
was the idea but it just kind of just
just boom after 92 knight b8 i am
not sure what is going on because
after knight ba it's just bishop g5
bishop f6 could be happening
um but then again i'm not entirely happy
about that
so it's just a little mind-blowing so if
you guys have any
solutions or suggestions for why
and what's going on i would love to hear
your feedback on this
um however white just like was like
okay i'll just put my cane in a safe
spot rook c4
let's put the king in safe spot this
kind of like fake castling is very
famous
yeah i mean i get that he's just waiting
but then he brings it back
so i am just like why on b8 why didn't
you go to d8
i get that like trying i understand that
trying to play knight to a5
it's not necessarily a good idea because
taking is possible
so just but why
b8 so he just kind of waited waited to
move and just like put the rook on c4
and then brought the knight out
and um after something like bishop
g5 now what do you think we should do as
black do should we care about this
bishop trying to jump into f6
[Music]
also probably because he's but between
ikea
maybe 98 looks weird so it might just
confuse why
potentially it could have been also
simply just psychology
behind it doesn't necessarily have to be
too deep
knight a5 was not exactly free because
the pawn v6 would defend it but right
now bishop f6 looks pretty scary so
let's go ahead and stop
that rook e8
and uh from what i
am aware of this both players at this
point were like
um getting to time travel so they didn't
necessarily want
to start messing it up so they probably
started playing too fast or whatnot
i like this idea of trying to bring more
pieces
in the game so right now the game is
very divided with black trying to do
stuff in the queen side while trying to
disturb the king side
so if somehow we could stop all the king
side attacks then black would be pretty
cool in the queen spot so let's start
with something like queen f7
um 98 also possible
but it's not exactly um
the the the perfect thing that we want
because that knight on f7 is just
weirdly placed even if you try to take
over there you lose on e6 and then white
is winning
so we shouldn't really um try for that
yeah the problem with an idea that this
kind of allows this knight to force
we need to keep this knight uh tied down
to
d4 so after rookie one
queen f7 now what should we do
let's say white is trying to free the
mind see upon defending the pawn
knight is freed up now what
now i think it's time to think about
this night right yeah
let's get this night going if you try to
be
funny i mean not necessarily funny but
funny to my pawns i can just come back
defend all these potential threats now i
want to jump to knights
when i jump with my knights to c4
now rook c6 what do you think black
white's gonna do
[Music]
we're finally about to get on c4
we've been wanting that c4 square
forever i agree with different pieces
we've been trying
now rashevsky made a mistake he played
bishop f6 check he did it too early it
was
totally wrong he should have tried to
bring a rook to
e3 either this rook and then try to
um like leave like a little trap on a3
and then try to just
push the drugs aside and try to go for a
serious attack there we go like this
or the other one would have
also probably worked like rook g rook
e3 knight c4 it goes away you try to
take again
check and then going for the e pawn so
he should have either tried to
attack the e pawn or the g pawn longer
term
but he kind of cracked and played bishop
f6 now bishop f6 is wrong i mean we only
literally have one
so we gotta do that move but we don't
have to take queen takes chapsticks
going take f6 is too early and we don't
want to do that just yet
so knight c4
simple and sweet now after
knight c4 this knight is attacking the
a3 pawn
my queen is attacking the f6 pawn but
this f6 pawn is also kind of covering my
king
so everything is kind of just weirdly
fine
so after knight c4
white plays queen to b1 um
again whites could have tried to
potentially play something like queen e2
trying to attack on e3 e6
but this doesn't exactly work because
again
boom uh pin no rookie trees either
because that just falls
so
in the game after knight c4 white played
queen b1 we eat the pawn
and now what do you think we should do
so
we can see that black's king is still
under pressure but black is making
progress so
what should we do
getting the queen to h4 is quite
interesting
a little too early though i agree a
little too early
why would they resign no no no we don't
resign here
um i like this idea of kicking the
knight so let's kick the knight
knight moves let's kick the rock brook
moves let's kick it more
rook gotta go all the way back and now
see we got so
much space and we just pushed the little
ponds and
managed to get that space and um
now we have an extra pond we got some
space
how should we continue that
yeah basically volcanic did use white
pawns to get in the way
and start to gain more space yep
now which piece could be improved let's
go with that
uh i agree this rook on c6
could be better so let's try to get this
rook rolling
now um what do you think should happen
here white play something if white play
if black played something like f3 and
try to keep pushing with the pond
not on g3 and then white could still oh
my god why do i keep saying white it's
black
black could still try to bring knight d2
knight d4 poke around i like this idea
too
this idea with trying to bring the
the knight around and poke a little more
and a little more efficient i love it
however i think that
um it might be a little bit more
interesting to play this rook c7
idea
oh hi sydney how is it how's it going
yeah
i think do you have the right idea with
my d2 threads
yeah yeah we have so many cool tactics
here now
rook c7 um now the thing
with rook c7 is that
here um i like it but it gives white a
little chance to
you know leave to like kind of little
leeway i guess is that the accurate
english term
so after queen b1 queen g6 attacking
but there's like little activity little
attack on my pawn even f3 g3
i don't really have that cool knight d2
knight e4 attacking here attacking their
idea anymore
but yeah
so after g3 um
[Music]
rook streak f7 is quite interesting
now after rook f7
what do you think black is gonna white's
gonna do
oh my god i keep getting my whites and
blacks wrong again
i don't know why
just because the position looks super
duper cool it doesn't mean that i need
it to be white
however this is french so i've always
been a little biased against french
this 95 idea potentially
so what about i like it okay let me
rephrase that
i think that you guys are um
on the money okay i need to learn my
phrases before i start using them
because then i have to keep questioning
myself
but i do think that you guys have the
right idea with a
knight e5 stuff if knight f4
it's also possible um knight f4
take take take and
this is how the game went and um
it's quite interesting because it's such
a great like
mini tactic but but let me go back
knight e5 would be better for white
because knight e5
take take and drook f5 is the way to go
and then if like queen goes to e1 you
still keep pressure
you still have a grip in the center you
still start
doing good you're still doing in the
center
keep pressure in the center at least
you're not letting the opponent just
ride on your king so um
however here knight f4
was played in the game good for us we
got a cool tactic out of it
boom boom bam and after queen b1
we're not gonna go um
try to move the the queen around however
we would play rook at five we're gonna
keep our queen there
and then boom g3
boom take and finally rook g5
so cool such a great position now rook
g2 coming up potential queen cedar is
coming up i just wish this knight was a
little closer
but yeah queen h3 rook g2
take 92 king moved and
what do you think is the final blow
roshewski is white that is true
thank you almost for helping in the chat
thank you yes
what do you think is the final move
any suggestions on how black can give
this final blow
thank you rana yes rook g3 and now this
is winning because
even if you try to be cute and take i
will still
eat one of your rooks and then this one
falls and everything falls
but if you try to be biased
less cute i would still eat one of your
wrecks and
that would be it so we looked at a game
of
ski but we need embedded in this there
were other games that were played by
great chess players
we looked at another game that winik
played
approximately 10 15 years out after this
game
uh we looked at it like many lines that
other greatest players such as the
sparrow short play
but yeah so i think this was a very very
brilliant game
i loved it um
almost knight c4 knight was on c4 so we
went to d2 to
do this rook g3 because even if we came
back
i mean if we didn't give this check it's
we can't really we don't have that
that many pieces we can't really get
this queen and grow because the rooks
are kind of defending a lot of the
squares that the queen can go to
so we have to be quite careful on this
but
overall i really like this game all
right guys let's take five
um let's take i'm gonna say 10 minutes
because i always say five and then it
gets to 10 minutes so let's take 10
minutes we are gonna switch to twitch
and uh we're gonna analyze your games so
please send me your games on leaches
have it's ready we're gonna go live in
about 10 minutes on twitch on our
segment of to switch to twitch
so join us there on twitch our
id is i believe a steal chess
shouldn't be too hard to find we will go
live soon
so uh join us send us our
your games preferably unleash us pg in a
pgn format or
a link any type of link that i can open
would be great
so uh i'll see you guys in about